was hatten wir kein glück und dann kam
auch noch pech dazu was man halt so sagt
wenn strategien und kampagnen krachend
scheitern dass astrazeneca vielleicht
nur vorübergehend auf dem index steht
bringt einen wackeligen und
unausgegorenen impfplan vollends
durcheinander
ein von corona unbeschwerter sommer
würde an ein wunder grenzen
das astra cdk debakel wie gefährdet ist
deutschlands impfkampagne jetzt in der
phoenix runde
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst im studio eva
quadbeck ist bei uns stellvertretende
chefredakteurin und leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros des redaktions netzwerks
deutschland die ulrichs ist professor an
der akad hochschule für
humanwissenschaften in berlin sie sind
im monologe epidemiologe und
gesundheitswissenschaftler zugeschaltet
ist susanne schreiber professorin für
neurowissenschaften an der
humboldt-universität hier in berlin sie
beschäftigen sich mit mathematischen
modellen von nervenzellen und ulrich
weigeldt ist bei uns der
bundesvorsitzende des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes nach unnötig jetzt
wieder unterrichts herr und rechts über
das stoppzeichen für als basilika wird
ja sehr kontrovers diskutiert hatte der
bundesgesundheitsminister denn keine
andere wahl oder blieb nichts anderes
übrig naja wenn das eigene
paul-ehrlich-institut diese empfehlungen
abgibt jetzt erstmal zu pausieren
dann kann man sich eigentlich immer nur
danach richten eigentlich schade dass
das jetzt so pausiert wurde und nicht
weiter gelaufen dass man jetzt weiter
laufen lassen weil ja jetzt hier diese
diskrepanz gerade entsteht dass wir
diese fälle klären müssen aber auf der
anderen seite dann jetzt eben
zehntausende menschen nicht impfen
können vorschreiber bei ihnen muss ich
noch nachliefern sie sind ja neben ihrer
professur hier in berlin auch noch
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
deutschen ethikrats für die impfkampagne
bei uns in deutschland ist ja das
aussetzen von astrazeneca möglicherweise
ein herber rückschlag
ja stimmen also vor allem wenn man die
risiken ab weg wenn man ihn sieht das
haben wir eine person von einer million
gefährdet ist eventuell durch
astrazeneca wenn dieser zusammenhang
bestätigt wird so muss man demgegenüber
stellen dass circa 1.000 personen von
einer million die nicht geimpft sind
gefährdet sind zu versterben durch kubik
und das ist schon eine eklatante
riskieren täglich menschenleben wenn
wenig
natürlich muss ist im jahr geprüft
werden aber es ist in jedem fall ein
rückschlag für die kampagne gottberg
egal was jens spahn macht macht er
offenbar im moment verkehrt selbst die
verschiebung des impfgipfel es jetzt um
zwei tage bringt in irgendwie in die
bredouille
jetzt muss man mal sagen bei dem thema
astrazeneca hat er so richtig in der
zwickmühle gesessen also hätte er gesagt
ich halte mich nicht an die empfehlung
des paul-ehrlich-instituts dann wäre
jeder tote geimpfte mit blutgerinnsel
sein toter gewesen
und wenn er sich daran hält ist es halt
auch schwierig weil da stimme ich frau
schneider zu in der risikoabwägung rhein
schon bauchgefühl hätte ich immer gesagt
dann kann man ja vielleicht die fälle
überprüfen während man weiter impft und
jetzt hat er den impf gipfel verschoben
weil es tatsächlich nicht so viel sinn
macht über die weitere impfkampagne zu
sprechen wenn man überhaupt nicht weiß
hat man astrazeneca oder nicht geplant
war ja dass man vor allen dingen auch
darüber spricht wie macht man das
logistische stellt man sich auf dass das
was die bundesregierung versprochen hat
dass nämlich im zweiten quartal so ein
richtiger boost beim impfen kommt dass
das auch funktioniert weil wenn man sich
im moment so anschaut was an ihm hängen
da ist dann sieht das nämlich noch nicht
danach aus und deshalb brauchen die auch
so dringend diesen impfgipfel die
hausärzte die warten ja auf verengten
vor allen dingen auch von astrazeneca
der geplante start für das impfen in
hausarztpraxen soll ja eigentlich der 19
april sein
ist dieser termin noch zu halten das
werden wir sehen weil es charakter eine
runde nach der anderen und man fragt
sich manchmal auch das motto heißt wie
schnell ist nichts passiert also es
warten ja nicht die hausärzte im grunde
genommen auf die impfung seien es waren
ja unsere patienten bzw die versicherten
auf die impfung und fragen uns die
kiefern geht es dann bei ihnen endlich
mal los ich möchte mich von meiner
hausärztin von meinem hausarzt impfen
lassen
und das hängt keineswegs nicht nur am
astra 10 i can't stop es gibt von den
impfstoffen her eigentlich keinen
sachlichen grund irgendeinen nicht in
der hausarztpraxis zu verkämpfen alles
das was wir am anfang gehört und gesehen
hatten das minus 70 grad gekühlte
impfstoff dann nicht transportabel ist
hat sich inzwischen geklärt und insofern
kann man einfach sagen wir müssen jetzt
da in die füße kommen wir müssen jetzt
loslegen
und natürlich ist dieser stopp jetzt
sehr ärgerlich zumal man vielleicht auch
überlegen könnte muss man dann an
generellen stopp einlegen wenn man
feststellt dass im grunde genommen ja
eine umschriebene patientengruppe oder
impf links gruppe besser in dem fall
betroffen wie es von denen von den von
den nebenwirkungen die natürlich auch
schlimm sind und sich überlegen ob man
nicht dann meinetwegen bei leuten über
60 die tiere offensichtlich nicht
betroffen sind dennoch weiterhin
zumindest bei denen die das wollen
herr unterrichts auch wenn wir jetzt
gerade bei dieser risikoabdeckung sind
die verschreiber gerade angesprochen hat
ist astrazeneca ein guter impfstoff auf
jeden fall also die daten die vorliegen
sprechen sehr dafür und zwar sowohl die
sicherheitsdaten als auch die
schutzwirkung wir haben studien
vorliegen aus ländern wo das schon sehr
stark verätzt worden ist also aus
großbritannien zum beispiel da gibt es
eine studie aus schottland also wo eben
klar gezeigt wird dass die schutzwirkung
zum beispiel vor eben schweren
erkrankungen schon nach der ersten
impfung da ist und es ist leider so dass
eben hass der astrazeneca impfstoff der
auch schon vor diesem stopp eine sehr
schlechte presse hatte eigentlich völlig
zu unrecht denn es ist eben ein gutes
wirkprinzip mit den sektor viren das
ebenso zu machen und die anderen gehen
parallel entwickelt worden sind also der
russische impfstoff sputnik 5 oder der
neue jetzt von johnson & johnson
basieren auf einem ähnlichen prinzip das
ist also alles gut etabliert und so gilt
es eben genauso für den astra zeneca
impfstoff vorschreiber diese presse
diese schlechte die teamer und richter
gerade angesprochen hat das bezog sich
auf studien die offensichtlich nicht
vollständig waren vor allem in den
höheren altersgruppen auch die geringere
wirksamkeit was ist aus ihrer sicht
eigentlich falsch gelaufen hätte da die
politik mehr eingreifen müssen mehr als
fürsprecher eines ja letztendlich dann
auch von der europäischen union und
von anderen institutionen genehmigten
impfstoff auftreten dass es erst gar
nicht jetzt mit diesem zweiten
rückschlag in eine solche schwierige
situation kommt ist es schwierig zu
sagen ob die politik dort noch mehr
hätte machen können also es ist immer
ganz wichtig aufzuklären
ich glaube die regierung hat schon
versucht sehr viele und informationen zu
vermitteln
ich glaube es war sehr problematisch
dass die studien ganz früh aus der
zulassung ja auch von der stadt durch
die presse gegangen sind und dass dann
diese zahlen kursiert
es gibt nur eine wirksamkeit von 60
prozent oder eventuell rund 70 prozent
und bei den studien das ist so schwierig
gelaufen bei der verschiedene gruppen
miteinander vermischt wurden das hat
natürlich nicht dazu beigetragen dass
das vertrauen entstehen konnte
ich glaube es ist wenn es erst einmal
verloren ist und diese daten kann man ja
auch nicht wahr eigentlichen dann ist es
gar nicht so leicht das wieder
einzufahren
ja also ich würde jetzt nicht mit dem
finger auf die politiker zeigen und
sagen da ist so wenig informiert worden
aber es ist einfach ein problem dass
diese studie die das weniger
durchgeführt hat von anfang an neben mit
technischen schwierigkeiten verbunden
war und jetzt dieser fall jetzt mit
diesen diesen thrombosen macht die sache
natürlich nicht leichter andererseits
weil ich ganz beeindruckt ich habe
gelesen dass in hamburg ja auch
gegenmaßnahmen ergriffen boden indem zum
beispiel beim ärzten und ihren
angestellten also ihren fachlichen
angestellten am wochenende ermöglicht wo
sich freiwillig impfen zu lassen ohne
termin und das wurde sehr sehr stark
wahrgenommen und hat dann auch dazu
geführt dass die patienten dieser ärzte
sich auch sehr gerne mit astrazeneca am
impfen lassen und das am termine nicht
mehr ausgefallen sind also ich denke es
gibt schon methoden da auch für
sicherheit zu sorgen da brauchst
vielleicht etwas kreativität eignet sich
eignen sich impfstoffe eigentlich für
politische auseinandersetzungen auch
wenn man jetzt diese diskussion
vorschreibe hat ja ganz am anfang gesagt
bei der risikoabwägung eins zu 1000
glaube ich also 1000 mal so viel so hoch
ist das todesrisiko wenn man weniger
nicht verimpft bekommt verglichen mit
den möglichen sehr seltenen
nebenwirkungen dass das jetzt gleich zur
politischen auseinandersetzungen vor
diesem hintergrund führt also für
politische auseinandersetzung oder
wahlkampfauseinandersetzung eignet sich
so eine pandemie eigentlich gar nicht
und das hat man ja im jahr 2020 auch
ganz gut hinbekommen dass das eben nicht
geschehen ist und wenn man darin die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz schaut dann
war das ja auch gar nicht so dass sie
sich nach parteibuch sortiert haben wer
jetzt er zum team öffnung mit der er zum
team vor sich gehörte sondern das waren
eher so regionale entscheidungen vor ort
wieder eine oder andere
ministerpräsident dann tickt ich möchte
aber auch noch gerne was zum thema
kommunikation sagen ich weiß gar nicht
ob das jetzt nur schlechte presse war
presse sap in so einem fall sowieso nur
katalysator einer situation also diese
studienergebnisse waren da und natürlich
werden sie dann publiziert und werden
dann eben auch in der presse vereinfacht
weil man eben nicht auf
wissenschaftlichem niveau in den medien
erklären kann weitergetragen und was die
bundesregierung dann aus meiner sicht
falsch gemacht hat ist dass sie nicht
diese debatte zugelassen hat und gesagt
hat ja es gibt eben auch grautöne bei
diesem impfstoff sondern es gab nur
schwarz und weiß und bis montagmorgen
war das ein super impfstoff und erst
gibt gepriesen worden und die regierung
hat auch so ein bisschen den eindruck
erweckt alle länder die jetzt abspringen
bei astrazeneca machen möglicherweise
ein fehler und montag gab es dann auf
einmal diese diese kehrtwende und sparen
hat eben auch gesagt wir machen hier
einen stopp
und ich glaube so was bei so was geht
dann vertrauen verloren aber vertrauen
geht gar nicht unbedingt verloren wenn
man den menschen erklärt es gibt auch
probleme aber nach der risikoabwägung
ist es so dass wir doch sagen wir für
impfen diesen stoff wenn man herbei die
da sagt nach der risikoabwägung wird der
impfstoff trotzdem er wird ja in einigen
ländern weiter geimpft obwohl man auch
gleichzeitig überprüft was ist mit
diesen neben nebenwirkungen wie
gravierend muss man sich denn diese
nebenwirkungen vorstellen
sie sind außerordentlich selten aber
wenn sie eintreten haben sie zumindest
bei der hälfte der fälle die wir kennen
in deutschland an den tödlichen verlauf
gut ob das die hälfte waren wir wissen
ist ja leider nicht genau und wir denken
schon in der kommunikation ist vieles
besser zu machen zum beispiel ärzte
vorher zu informieren bevor sie
sozusagen den ganzen tag astra zenica
impfen und empfehlen und dann kommt
mittags eine pressekonferenz
zudem wissen wir spezifischer welche
bevölkerungsgruppen oder welche gruppen
von den impfungen betroffen sind
es gibt nebenwirkungen die diskutiert
worden sind dass diese kopfschmerzen da
kann man sagen lieber zwei tage
kopfschmerzen als sechs wochen kobelt es
gibt eben nebenwirkungen die
gefährlicher sind und diese hirn
venenthrombosen sind eine gefährliche
erkrankung die zum glück insgesamt sehr
selten ist und dass auch in diesen
fällen selten aufgetreten
man muss das exakt und sauber
untersuchen und gut kommuniziert und zur
kommunikation vielleicht noch eins
zahlen 1 2001 zu 100 das ist für die
meisten menschen komplett abstrakt die
kommunikation müsste eigentlich
tatsächlich mehr dahin laufen was habe
ich davon wenn ich mich impfen
die bienen beispiel menschen die in
einem risikogebiet fahren um eine kenya
safari zu machen nehmen eine
gelbfieberimpfung und fragen nach nichts
und haben zwei tage kopfschmerzen
gliederschmerzen und liegen auf der nase
sie haben aber was davon
also insofern sollte man daraus lernen
zu sagen welche vorteile gibt es für den
einzelnen und welche für die
gesellschaft und das plastisch und
stärker aus ich glaube diese
zahlenspiele die sind für die meisten
menschen wie gesagt ziemlich abstrakt
und machen trotzdem eher an als dass die
vertrauen fördern unterwegs sind diese
nebenwirkungen aber in der welt hören
venenthrombose oder silos venenthrombose
vielleicht kurz erklären was geht da
eigentlich im körper vor sich was ist
daran so gefährlich und warum passiert
das möglicherweise nach der
verabreichung dieses im schloss ja also
der causa hans zusammenhang ist ja noch
nicht ganz geklärt also oder überhaupt
noch offensichtlicher dass man
möglicherweise genau und es ist so dass
so thrombosen ja auftreten können aus
verschiedenen gründen also wenn das blut
langsam fließt also zum beispiel bei
langstreckenflügen und so und eben auch
also noch beispielsweise bei einnahme
der pille ist das auch noch möglich und
wenn eben auch bei infektionen das
auftritt dann gibt es eben bestimmte
kristallisationspunkte wo die gerinnung
eben stattfinden kann
es ist übrigens auch eine schwere folge
von der gofit 19 erkrankungen
und das kann eben dann auch passieren
also die genauen zusammenhänge wie
gesagt kennt man ja gar nicht das ist
daneben auch die venen trifft am gehirn
und da ist es natürlich mit der
blutversorgung besonders kritisch dass
das also aufrecht erhalten wird und es
hat dann entsprechend kann schlimme
folgen haben
und das ist eine sehr seltene
konstellation dass das eben diese venen
da betrifft also deswegen muss davon ist
nicht verwechseln mit der tiefen
beinvenenthrombose zum beispiel und eben
einen anderen traum traumatischen
ereignissen aber es ist eben wie hawaii
gilt ja schon gerade richtig sagte eben
schon also mit sehr vielen schlimmen
konsequenzen verbunden weil es eben eben
an dem kritischen gewebe des gehirns ist
es gibt ja immer wieder vergleiche ich
sagte ja gerade problem problematisiert
wird die korona schutzimpfungen während
eine mit ähnlichen nebenwirkungen
versehene gelbfieberimpfung für
touristen ganz normal hingenommen wird
jetzt wird ja auch oft dass mit dem mit
der einnahme der antibabypille
verglichen kann man das so vergleichen
das erste seminar und den wirkstoff den
die pille hat natürlich gar nicht also
das 100 jahr wieder genau das wurde
immer wieder herbei weil das auch
thrombose verursachen könnte
das einzige was man vielleicht
vergleichen könnte ist dass man die
pille auch in einem gesunden zustand
nimmt um etwas zu verhindern nämlich die
schwangerschaft und in diesem fall gibt
man den impfstoff um etwas zu verhindern
nämlich eine möglicherweise schwer
verlaufende infektionskrankheit
also man gibt es gesunden so und aber
dann hört es auch schon auf also das was
eben die die pille hervorrufen kann das
sind eben die klassischen thrombosen und
eben auch mit einer ganz anderen
wahrscheinlichkeit als jetzt hier wir
sprechen ja schon sehr sehr seltenen
ereignissen und eben wie gesagt der
direkte zusammenhang muss ja erst noch
genauer untersucht werden und aber wenn
dem so sein sollte dann haben wir hier
eben ein sehr seltenes ereignis und das
muss man ganz strikt trennen von den
viel viel häufigeren leichten
nebenwirkungen den vorübergehenden die
auftreten können wie eben bei der
erwähnten gelbfieberimpfung dass die
menschen dann halt mal zwei tage flach
liegen ich hatte die auch schon mal
bekommen
danach habe ich mich gefühlt als hätte
ich den halben kasten bier getrunken und
das geht aber daneben vorüber und das
ist etwas was also ja auch auftritt bei
der
astrazeneca impfung dass das ist die
eine sache das sind leichte dinge und
dass die zeigen ja auch nichts anderes
als dass das immunsystem eben auf die
impfung reagiert sich damit
auseinandersetzt trainiert wird das sind
also klassische zeichen dafür so etwas
wie diese traumatischen ereignisse oder
auch das was ja auch in sehr seltenen
fällen vorkommt eine schwere allergische
reaktion das tritt unmittelbar nach der
pause kann in seltenen fällen nach der
impfung direkt auftreten
da ist es klar dass das dann davon
hervorgerufen wird da ist man aber
darauf vorbereitet und kann dann
entsprechend sofort eingreifen
vorschreiber es war ja bei den bei dem
asta senica impfstoff bei der zulassung
zunächst mal so dass die älteren gar
nicht geimpft werden sollten damit nur
die jüngeren
jetzt zeigt sich ja dass diese
nebenwirkung von astrazeneca vor allen
dingen bei jüngeren auftritt vor allem
bei jüngeren frauen zwischen 20 und 50
jahren sollte man da möglicherweise auch
überlegen ob man nicht nur die
impfstoffe wieder zu tag neu ausrichtet
auf andere altersgruppen als bisher
vorgesehen also die jüngeren eigentlich
mit beyond mit dem genetisch
produzierten impfstoff den sogenannten
mrsa impfstoffen zu impfen und die
älteren mit astrazeneca und hat das auch
folgen für die im freien folge die er
der ethikrat ganz mühsam erarbeitet hat
ja also ich habe ihn jetzt keine
medizinerin kann natürlich jetzt nicht
bewerten für welche altersgruppe
geeignet ich finde aber diese vorschläge
gerade weil die nebenwirkungen bei der
älteren bevölkerung in geringer sind
astrazeneca wenn es wieder zugelassen
ist für die für die älteren personen zu
verwenden und vion tag für die jüngeren
weil dort auch sehr stark die
transmission also die ansteckung
vermindert wird und die jüngeren ja auch
noch mehr unterwegs sind und auch noch
potenzial heute anstecken finde ich
eigentlich eine sehr gute idee
man muss immer gucken mit der
priorisierung da würde ich noch mal ganz
kurz ausholen der ethik art hat er
gemeinsam mit der leopoldina der
ständigen impfkommission sich gedanken
dazu gemacht wie man zu einer
priorisierung kommen könnte und es war
ganz klar dass das oberste ziel sein
sollte die schweren
heute zu verhindern also insbesondere
besondere zuerst personen zu schützen
die ein hohes risiko haben
das ist in der verordnung umgesetzt
worden indem man gesagt hat eben die
älteren bevölkerungsteile aber man hat
doch eine gewisse gruppe vergessen dass
es gab nachbesserungsbedarf weil die
jüngeren patienten auch mit schweren
vorerkrankungen nicht dabei waren und
insofern finde ich dass man bei der
priorisierung jetzt unbedingt darauf
achten muss mit ein problem die sie auch
mit sich bringt dass wir aber genau
diese personen die das hohe risiko haben
aber unter 80 jahren als sind es die
wirklich berücksichtigt werden insofern
stehe ich persönlich eine aufweichung
einer solchen priorisierung skeptisch
gegenüber aber natürlich brauchen wir
müssen pragmatisch ansetzen
der hintergrund bei der frage frau
schreiber war gewesen wenn jetzt
astrazeneca hat ja nicht nur jetzt ein
problem mit den nebenwirkungen sondern
auch ein liefer problem wenn jetzt sehr
viel mehr m rna impfstoffe also diese
modernen impfstoffe von moderner und von
bayern wegweiser zum einsatz kommt bei
jüngeren und die astrazeneca impfstoffe
denn ältere nicht gegeben werden oder
auf ab reicht werden können weil das zu
wenig da ist würde sich ja automatisch
eine umkehrung der reihe der im freien
folge ergeben
das heißt dass man viel mehr dann
jüngere als ältere impfen wird also zum
einen hat man ja schon einen großteil
der über 80-jährigen gedämpft und zum
anderen ist es wirklich ganz wichtig zu
sehen dass auch der ethikrat damals
gesagt hat es geht darum das risiko und
alter ist nur ein indikator risiko aber
eigentlich ist das risiko fast
altersunabhängig ja so natürlich sind
mehr ältere personen von vorerkrankungen
getroffen aber es gibt auch genügend
jüngere personen vor erkrankung die man
dann genauso mit biontech impfen plan
und natürlich hängt das alles an den
hängen sie sollte dann wenn wir nur bei
montie ketten natürlich so gut für
ältere personen als auch für ihn
eingesetzt werden dass ihre frage ja das
war die 2
es verkehrt sich jetzt ein bisschen so
die ganze ausrichtung der impfstoffe
erwarte ich weiß nicht ob ich sie davor
hin richtig verstanden habe man hat ja
eine zeit lang gesagt als dass weniger
besonders für die hausärzte dass es
leicht zu händeln dieser vector
impfstoff ist nicht so kompliziert er
ist leichter zu transportieren leichter
zu lagern
aber sie haben gesagt das sei ja im
prinzip ja auch mit denen den m rna
impfstoffen jetzt gelöst das heißt also
in den hausarztpraxen können nicht nur
diese vector impfstoffe wie astrazeneca
verimpft werden sondern eben auch die
etwas komplizierteren impfstoffe wie von
beyond inc pfizer und von moderner auf
jeden fall also man muss vielleicht dazu
sagen das habe ich gesagt am anfang war
eben auch viel vorsicht geboten
diese impfstoffe sind neu man musste
damit im umgang sehr aufpassen dass man
keine fehler macht und es hat sich im
laufe der zeit die erfahrung
herausgebildet dass das sehr wohl geht
in den praxen es gibt an einem baden
württemberg 40 pilot praxen bei
hausärzten die nur bayern kämpfen und
wohl nicht aufgetreten ist was in
irgendeiner weise negativ in erscheinung
getreten ist also insofern gibt es
eigentlich keinen sachlichen grund das
nicht zu tun
sie haben vorhin ich weiß nicht es war
gesagt da haben sich die ärzte impfen
lassen und dann haben die patienten
gesagt da mache ich das auch genau das
ist der grund weswegen man auch zu den
hausärzten geben muss ich glaube auch
das zweite auch was frau schreiber jetzt
gesagt hat wer weiß in welche patienten
welche krankheiten haben das callcenter
das impfzentrum wir wissen es nicht die
können es nicht wissen
und ich glaube wir können auch diese
patienten daten nicht einfach in der
gegend rum werfen nur mit irgendjemand
das weiß wir wissen dass wir kennen
unsere patienten und es geht auch nicht
unbedingt um auf reichen das klingt
immer noch ein bisschen negativ dieser
reihenfolge die dort festgelegten ist
aber es gibt dass die alternative ist
aber auch nicht das grafische und
gnadenlose durchziehen
und wenn man dann sieht was in der
wirklichkeit passiert dann stellen sie
fest dass natürlich übrig bleibende
impfstoffe in irgend jemandes arm
gestochen werden ob das praktikanten
oder
die kriterien sind im krankenhaus das
passiert alles in der bild zeitung
beschwert sie ein 52-jähriger
gewerkschafter der polizeigewerkschaft
will sie jetzt niveau sein zweiter im
stoff her kommt da frage ich mich wo ist
der denn der reihenfolge
dennoch glaube ich dass wir
grundsätzlich das einhalten müssen ich
begrüße auch sehr diese betrachtung zu
sagen lasst uns trocken wer hat welche
krankheiten und wenn ein 65-jähriger
diabetiker mit hochdruck und übergewicht
in der reihenfolge hinter einem 74
jährigen der gerade das sportabzeichen
gemacht hat steht dann ist natürlich
schon die frage für uns wir um müssen
wir jetzt das anwenden das was wir dort
haben und ich glaube sogar wenn ich mit
dem 74 jährigen dann spreche und sagt
wir haben einen der hat ein höheres
risiko als du ist aber noch nicht dran
lässt du den in der reihe vor dann gibt
es überhaupt gar kein problem
das heißt die hause erste soll auch die
hausärzte sollen da auch verstehe ich
jetzt richtig soll auch mehr kompetenzen
bekommen mehr flexibilität bei der
festlegung der in freien folge aufgrund
auch ihrer patienten patientenakten wo
sie ja dann auch erkennen können sie
haben gerade beispiel genannt wäre es
möglicherweise nötige hat als jemand
anderes
also ich glaube dass das wahr wenn die
frau schreiber machen wir widersprechen
aber dass das ist auch glaube ich da
angelegt zu sagen wir müssen wir müssen
sehen wer hat das höhere risiko und das
risiko alter plus erkrankung ist
sozusagen erkrankungs gewichtiger bei
jüngeren patienten
wir haben die über 80-jährigen fast alle
gibt das ist das entscheidet die über
80-jährigen hatten im jahre 2020 die
über sterblichkeit das war die wohl
beste gruppe und da war es auch richtig
und notwendig eine strenge im freien
folge zu haben um diese erstmal zu
schützen das hat sich auch bewährt
jetzt sehen wir aber dass der
unterschied zwischen einem 62 oder
72-jährigen mag ja sein im
kalendarischen alter das biologische
alter muss man auch denken ich glaube
dass wir hier die leitlinie haben der
der der imf reihenfolge um das man
bieber alt leitlinien sagen muss man
muss aus medizinischen
könnten davon abweichen können das muss
man auch begründen das tun wir ja auch
wir würden ja dann in unserer
dokumentation haben warum ist jetzt
beispielsweise in dem beispiel von mir
der 65-jährige vorher geimpft worden das
lässt sich dann ja auch nachprüfen also
insofern glaube ich dass man dass man im
kopf haben muss wie dieser reihenfolge
geht und wenn jetzt wenn jetzt dass mit
dem impfstoff durcheinander geht dass
man sagt man muss jetzt die die astra im
stoffe kann man den älteren geben wir es
übrigens was die englischen studien
zeigen dass es sogar für ältere
günstiger ist den astra zu nehmen als
den anderen
da lernen wir ja auch dazu das muss man
einfach da kann man niemandem
irgendwelche schuld geben das muss man
dazu lernt man muss natürlich keine
lapidaren äußerung von wegen dumm
gelaufen oder so was raus tun aber
grundsatz haben wir dazugelernt und ich
glaube da sind wir auch gar nicht in
konflikt mit dem ethikrat wenn man sagt
dieses dazulernen muss dazu führen dass
wir hier auch effektiv und vernünftig
damit umgehen und das tun wir glaube ich
auch und ich glaube dafür braucht ist
die hausärztliche impfung bald dort
laufen die daten zusammen und lassen sie
mich ein letztes dazu sagen
alle folgen einer impfung werden bei uns
bei unseren betreuten patienten jahr
gesehen und unmittelbar gesehen eine
impfung die in einem briefzentrum
stattgefunden hat ist sozusagen für das
impfzentrum immer folgenlos weil das hat
nach dem ausscheiden des patienten aus
diesem aus dieser messehalle
ich habe das selbst erlebt ist man da
ist das fertig ebenso groß sie haben
jetzt das den ethikrat da sozusagen in
anfangszeit in mithaftung genommen aber
wenn ich jetzt frau schreiber richtig
gesehen habe hat sie da ja genügt also
das heißt das was jetzt gezielt worden
ist was die kompetenz der hausärzte
angeht auch bei der im freien folge das
trägt der ethikrat somit genau wenn ich
da kurz kommentieren also ich bin sehr
einverstanden mit dem sie sagen
verweigert weil das problem ist ja
tatsächlich dass die eigentlich ethische
intendierte reihenfolge bisher nur sehr
sehr schwach zum zug
bei den über 80 jährigen ist es sehr gut
dann lief es gut aber ich würde ganz
gerne mal zahlen aus berlin anführen das
ist jetzt nicht um mir ich entschuldige
mich bei allen berlinern und mit ziel
berlin zu passion aber ich habe heute im
robert-koch-institut mal nachgeschaut
berlin hat jetzt mittlerweile knapp
500.000 personen gegen 400 noch was 1000
und das robert koch institut zählt auf
was die indikation sind dafür da gibt es
200.000 ungefähr an erstimpfung habe ich
jetzt im kopf die altersbedingt sind und
wenn man dann aber guckt medizinische
indikation also nicht alters sondern aus
vorerkrankung gründen und das müssen
dann ja die jüngeren patienten sein
da hat berlin 150 ja und jetzt denken
wir dran ich hab eben gesagt fast eine
halbe million sind geben das heißt wir
haben wirklich dieses bürokratische
problem dass die vorerkrankung gar nicht
gut erfasst werden können und berlin
geht da einen recht umständlichen weg
mit einladungen und jetzt über die
kassenärztliche vereinigung wo man jetzt
versucht diese diagnosen zu bekommen und
dann hofft man bis ende april die ersten
also nicht erst aber diese priorisierung
gruppe 3 sind nach § 3 die zweite gruppe
einladen zu können und dann dauert es
vielleicht noch mal im monat bis diese
patienten einen termin erhalten und dann
sind wir irgendwann gemein und das ist
viel zu spät weil diese personen sollten
eigentlich ganz am anfang mit ran kommen
und da sind die hausärzte bieten
natürlich eine wundervolle gelegenheit
bei genauso wie sie geschrieben haben
sie kennen ihre patienten und es kommt
ja nicht darauf an ob die diagnose a
oder b und ob es dann mathematisch ganz
genau ist sondern es geht wirklich darum
dass die leute die dort einen bedarf
haben die ein hohes risiko tragen dass
die auch erfasst werden und für mich
persönlich ist das möglich der
hauptpunkt an der priorisierung neben
dem schutz des medizinischen personals
und alles andere ist dann danach was das
kann man vielleicht auch politisch
entscheiden da geht es natürlich auch um
exposition und ähnliches aber diese
person die haben ja nur um das noch mal
zu verdeutlichen da gibt es personen die
dialyse patienten sind oder die
krebspatienten sind die haben auch wenn
sie jünger sind ein risiko wenn sie sich
infizieren dass 30 prozent übersteigt
dann daran zu versterben und das ist
deutlich höher als das risiko eines
gesunden 80-jährigen ja und weil diese
person vernachlässigen wir im moment
zumindest in teilen und dann können die
hausärzte wirklich sehr sehr gut helfen
das wäre wunderbar wenn jedoch mit
gut dass muss jetzt endlich die politik
eine einsicht haben 1 1 eine einsicht
haben dass das so passiert weil ich
komme gleich nochmal zu ihnen zurück zu
astrazeneca hat vielleicht noch oder
wollten sich noch etwas zu früh
nein ich wollte noch mal ganz also beide
statements noch mal wirklich richtig
unter unterstreichen das ist ein ganz
starkes argument für das verimpft
in den hausarztpraxen das eben genau
diese übersicht da ist und dass man
tatsächlich jetzt hier im geiste dieser
priorisierung daneben auch vorgehen kann
und es ist ja wir sehen in den 16
bundesländern sehr unterschiedlich
gehandhabt wie das in den impfzentren
läuft und auch mit den organisatorischen
hürden und auch diesen zeitverzögerungen
deswegen ist das also wirklich sehr
sinnvoll
vielleicht mit einer kleinen
einschränkung wenn wir sie jetzt schon
entsprechend uns vorstellen weil dieser
relative oder absolute impfstoff
knappheit dann verlagern wir die
knappheit ja auch noch in die
hausarztpraxen und das ist natürlich
dann schwierig dann ist da ja auch noch
die bürde daneben den patienten zu sagen
dass ich ja eigentlich nur wenn
tatsächlich genügend genügend
entschlossen da sind sind dann das heißt
beginnt wird es die ins zentrum kommen
ja immer wieder mal ein spieler lässt
sich nicht immer etwas positives
berichten dass in organisatorische
probleme
auch die frage von impfterminen gibt es
immer wieder ärger
wenn man jetzt so die argumente von ein
wald gehört hat dann könnte man ja sagen
möglicherweise sind ja sobald das ihnen
bei den hausärzten richtig gut läuft
diese impfzentren überflüssig ja ich
möchte da inhaltlich gar nicht
widersprechen auch dass eine
priorisierung sicherlich in den praxen
sinnvoll wäre ich gehe mal davon aus
dass die allermeisten hausärzte das
wirklich nach bestem wissen und gewissen
machen würden aber der flaschenhals den
wir haben ist er tatsächlich der
impfstoff also wenn man jetzt auch noch
mal auf die seite des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums guckt wo
ja dann auch gezeigt wird wie viele
impfdosen wir waren erwarten dass er
wird jetzt bis ende märz plätschern noch
ein paar hunderttausend von moderner
rein und nochmal ein paar guten nochmal
eine millionen von astrazeneca und bei
beyond wird schon wieder gewarnt dass
die märz dosen noch gar nicht alle
produziert sind die da in aussicht
gestellt sind das heißt wir haben nach
wie vor eine absolute knappheit des
impfstoffs und solange ist es dann
einfach auch schwierig denen die
hausarztpraxen zu geben weil
jeder hausarzt praxis 30 oder 50
impfdosen bekommt in der woche dann ist
die enttäuschung natürlich auch relativ
groß und dann ist es auch schwierig so
eben danach vor zu gehen dass man sagt
man ist jetzt auch ein bisschen
großzügiger was die regeln angeht dann
wird es nämlich doch im endeffekt zu
auseinandersetzungen kommen und die
politik muss muss muss jetzt dafür
sorgen dass das was sie in aussicht
gestellt hat auch tatsächlich nach
deutschland geliefert wird und dann kann
man nur hoffen dass wenn die sich am
freitag zu ihrem sogenannten impfgipfel
zusammensetzen dass sie da noch eine
wegweisende lösung haben gut dazu musste
ja auch dieser impfstoff immer
produziert werden denn wollen ihn ja
alle wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz after
weniger betrachten da schlummern jetzt
gerade 1,4 millionen dosen glaube ich in
kühlschränken in deutschland die im
moment nicht verimpft werden selbst wenn
jetzt die ära die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ein unbedenklichkeit
zeugnis für astrazeneca ausstellt könnte
es ja sein dass diese 1,4 millionen
dosen zu ladenhütern notieren
jetzt gibt es den vorschlag bei
astrazeneca sollte man das sowieso
völlig aus der imf reihenfolge
rausnehmen und sagen damit hat gestern
ein politiker dietmar bartsch von der
partei die linke gefordert und damit
jeden der will und möchte und das also
unabhängig sondern einfach nur
freiwillige vor ist das eine sinnvolle
sinnvoller eine sinnvolle verwendung von
astrazeneca
na ja das würde eigentlich das was
festgelegt worden ist als priorisierung
und zwar aus guten gründen festgelegt
worden dass unterlaufen und würde das
was wir ja auch noch erreichen wollen
dass wir jetzt nach den über 80-jährigen
auch die nächsten die auch ein hohes
risiko haben bedenken
eben dann dass das nicht nicht wahr
werden würde das war aber wir haben eben
diese dieses hohe risiko den
nächstfolgenden gruppen und deswegen
wäre es eigentlich sinnvoll die dann
dazu zu impfen und weil wenn die sich
zieren obwohl es eigentlich nötig hätten
besonders nötig hätten geimpft zu werden
wir sagen aber bitte nicht mit diesem
astrazeneca das ist eigentlich so bisher
nicht erkennbar und man habe ich das
könnt ihr jetzt passieren durch diese
wirkungen ja also aber da würde ich doch
einfach mal darauf vertrauen dass wenn
man das also wirklich gut kommuniziert
das ist eben mit diesem impfstoff so ist
und sie hatten ja schon gerade erwähnt
also es ist eben nicht schwarz-weiß sein
es sind eben auch graustufen dabei und
es gibt eben möglicherweise sehr
schwerwiegende aber eben sehr sehr
seltene nebenwirkungen das ist ja bei
anderen impfstoffen bei anderen
infektionen auch der fall dann dann kann
man das eben auch durchaus vertreten und
auch rüberbringen dass eben astrazeneca
auch ein impfstoff der wahl ist und eben
gut verimpft werden kann also ich würde
mich damit auch impfen lassen
schreiber noch ein anderer aspekt soll
ja jetzt eine impfstoff not kommen wir
haben es schon angesprochen
möglicherweise kommen jetzt wesentlich
mehr impfstoffe hat zumindest der
fachlich gar nicht zu geständige
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz
angekündigt möglicherweise in seiner
zweiten funktion als kanzlerkandidat der
spd muss man wenn dann tatsächlich
ausreichend impfstoff da es sind auch
sehr viele geimpft worden sind auch
wieder über die privilegien räten für
die mutigen die sich impfen lassen dass
sie eben dann von bestimmten maßnahmen
eines lockt das von beschränkungen
kontakt beschränkungen
reisebeschränkungen befreit werden
ja ich glaube sie haben anfang der
gleich noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
zumindest ethischer sicht für dieses
wort privilegien gar nicht gerne
benutzen weil es ja doch um die
rückerstattung von freiheiten geht und
von grundrechten die eigentlich unter
normalen rutschte in brasilien gegenüber
den noch nicht mobil sind und sich noch
nicht bewegen können meine ich das ist
klar wir haben eigentlich privilegien
sind relativ aber trotzdem muss man
natürlich erst mal zur kenntnis nehmen
dass wenn man als geimpfter ein recht
zurückbekommt dass es dann doch erstmal
eine rückerstattung von von und rechten
ist ich glaube darauf zielt ja ihre
finale und wird man auch mal das jetzt
machen sich das richtige mann für die
die sich im fall sozusagen als belohnung
dafür dass ich hab impfen lassen oder
sie da hingegangen sind zu sagen jetzt
sind ausreichend genügend leute geimpft
also können wir schon mal die ersten
freiheiten aber selektiert wieder
selektiv zu lassen also das ist
natürlich dann schon ein privileg weil
andere die nicht geimpft sind die
gefährdet sein können oder
möglicherweise noch andere gefährden
weil sie noch nicht geimpft sind eben
nicht kriegen können die frage ist ja
ist dass diese diskussion ist ja auch
mit dem begriff privilegien immer wieder
geführt worden schon lange bevor
überhaupt klar war waren genügend
impfstoffe da sind ist das eine
diskussion die man dann noch mal führen
muss dass man dann tatsächlich so eine
art zwei-klassen-gesellschaft eine
zeitlang übergangsweise hat ja es ist
eine diskussion die ethisch auch
wirklich schwierig ist der ethikrat hat
sich damit beschäftigt wir haben eine
stellungnahme dazu verfasst anfang des
jahres wo man sagen dass das wichtigste
was erstmal gesichert sein muss es dass
die geimpften auch nicht mehr ansteckend
sind
in dem moment wo man auch weiterhin
ansteckend ist auch wenn man selber
geschützt ist ist man ja gut er noch
eine gefahr für andere und dann wird es
schwierig egal ob das jetzt
privilegieren wo der stadt doch von
rechten nennt wenn sich aber
herausstellt dass die ansteckung stark
gemindert wird zumindest viveon tech
deutet sich das jetzt an wenn man die
israelischen zahlen anguckt dann bin ich
ist schon legitim darüber nachzudenken
dass man auch besondere rechte für die
geimpften einführt und die sache ist
aber komplex weil man muss natürlich
bedenken das ist umso schwieriger wenn
wir jetzt noch knapp impfstoff haben und
wenn einige personengruppen solidarisch
zurückstehen und sagen ich bin damit
einverstanden sich jetzt noch nicht
geimpft werde damit die besonders
wohlhabende fortschritt haben und dann
bekommen diese person dann aber auch
noch extra rechte hinzu wer das ist dass
es für diese zweiklassengesellschaft
oder für dieses gerechtigkeitsempfinden
für einige problematisch auf der anderen
seite gibt es die rechtliche seite das
eigentlich dann ja auch der grund für
die einschränkungen wegfällt und man
kann auch die pandemie einschränkende
seite sehen dass zum beispiel wenn man
jetzt einmal reisen so ein irres hätte
das gibt natürlich auch eine gute
sicherheit ja irgendwie ansonsten auch
quarantänemaßnahmen zurückgreifen die
vielleicht auch nicht hundertprozentig
befolgt werden dann weiß man mit seinem
dokumentationen über die impfung schon
woran man ist es ist eine sehr diffizile
angelegenheit und als ethikrat haben wir
fast nur angedeutet
diese sicherheit der nicht ansteckung
kommt dann muss man ausprobieren schritt
für schritt und schauen was kann man
zurückerstatten an freiheiten und wo
gibt es auch um ein schwenkbarer ganz
klar dass der einsatz der invasion des
services eingeschränkt sind so was wie
der öffentliche nahverkehr ja dass das
muss allen zugänglich sein egal ob gm
nicht gut der digitale impfpass der ist
ja heute von der europäischen kommission
sozusagen in auftrag gegeben worden da
gibt es auch noch große bedenken die
südeuropäischen länder sind da sehr
dafür deutschland frankreich haben aus
gründen des datenschutzes und auch wegen
dieser möglichen ihn denn diesmal
neiddebatte auch dann noch bedenken ich
stelle mich jetzt vor kurz vor den
sommerferien es ist doch nicht so viel
impfstoff angekommen gibt noch sehr
viele gerade der jüngeren menschen in
deutschland die noch keine impfung haben
und wir haben auch noch gleichzeitig ein
bundestagswahlkampf und dann bringt eine
solche diskussion auf wer darf jetzt was
und wer das noch nicht
kommt die politik da in eine schwierige
situation fertig leuchtete auf ein
gefährliches politisches risse auf also
zwei antworten hat so das eine ist dass
sich bei dem thema auf jeden fall auch
die macht des faktischen durchsetzen
wird wenn zum beispiel ein veranstalter
von kreuzfahrten sagt ich lass einfach
nur geimpfte an bord weil es wäre völlig
wahnsinnig wenn dieses virus bei mir an
bord ausbricht dann kann der das machen
weil er sein privatunternehmer und kann
einfach sagen nur wer den nachweis
erbringt kann bei mir auch eine reise
buchen das ist so dass eine das heißt
damit wird sich das sukzessive
durchsetzen
und dann dieser europäische impfpass ist
in der theorie eine hübsche idee aber
wenn man jetzt mal schaut dass die jetzt
noch exakt zwei monate zeit haben um das
ding durchzusetzen und dafür bräuchte es
pragmatismus schnelligkeit und einigkeit
um da wirklich eine europäische lösung
zu finden und da sind ja jetzt nur alles
drei eigenschaften die man sehr selten
in der europäischen union findet deshalb
vermute ich einfach mal dass dieser
dieser impfpass dieser europäische
grüner pass soll heißen die frau von der
leyen heute gesagt hat gar nicht so
richtig zum zuge kommen wird und am ende
wird jedes land da seine eigenen
bestimmungen haben meinetwegen gibt es
einen code der europäisch abgesegnet ist
aber natürlich werden die italiener am
andere regelungen haben als
beispielsweise manuela schwäche sich in
mecklenburg vorpommern fast jedes land
soll ja auch den qr-code dann selbst
entwickeln für diesen gemeinsamen
digitalen in fast verwickelt sehen sie
auch gefahren für das also in der zeit
in der noch nicht durch geimpft ist oder
diese immunität sozusagen landesweit
besteht zwischen der gruppe der nicht
geimpften und der geimpften dass sich da
was hochschaukeln könnte einerseits dass
man sich ärgert dass wir noch nicht dran
war oder dass man glaubt eben wenn
länder oder kreuzfahrtschiffe wie jetzt
vor platt gesagt hat eben eine impfung
vorschreiben dass man da nicht zum zuge
kommt und dass das dann zu konflikten
führt vielleicht auch in hausarztpraxen
unter ihren patienten also dass bei uns
in den praxen glaube ich nicht glaube da
muss man sich auch was die im freien
folge angeht nicht so viel gedanken
machen und muss nicht die impfzentren
privilegieren
das muss man noch mal sagen wir haben
400 tausend leute die in der
häuslichkeit leben und die ohne weiteres
in die risikogruppe gehören die von den
zentren nicht erfasst werden also da
wäre ich mal vorsichtig und mal gucken
wer da rein geht aber in der tat ist es
so dass wenn man das führt dann kann es
natürlich auch zu konflikten kommen aber
ich glaube man kann mit vernünftiger und
guter argumentation und guter
kommunikation sagen wir arbeiten alle
daran dass wir möglichst tatsächlich
schnell damit durch sind deswegen müssen
wir einfach jetzt geschwindigkeit
aufnehmen die leute sind ungeduldig und
es liegen ja nicht nur 1,6 millionen
astra impfstoff warum seine es liegen ja
weitere zwei millionen oder zweieinhalb
millionen irgendwo rum und keiner weiß
wo das ist aber wenn sie gucken was ist
bestellt und bekommen was haben wir
bekommen und was ist verimpft haben sie
immer eine grosse differenz das heißt
wir müssen geschwindigkeit aufnehmen und
das führt auch dazu dass vertrauen gibt
auch vielleicht bei denen die jetzt noch
ein bisschen warten müssen meinen
eindruck aus der praxis nur ganz kurz
ist dass die menschen dafür verständnis
haben dass zunächst die älteren und die
kranken geimpft werden das ist nicht
unbedingt per se an konfliktstoff
jetzt gibt es bei astrazeneca viele
menschen die erst geimpft sind aber
jetzt nicht genau wissen wann die zweite
impfung kommt jetzt gibt es ja schon
ideen die gab es auch vorher schon auch
wegen der geringeren wirksamkeit von
astrazeneca ob man nicht einen impfstoff
nix anbietet das heißt mit astrazeneca
die ersten impfungen dann mit einem
wegweiser oder moderner impfstoff die
zweit und vielleicht auch die dritte
impfung macht das eigentlich sinn auch
aus medizinischer hinsicht verschiedene
impfstoffe anzuwenden um möglicherweise
auch die die währungsabwertung stärken
im körper breiter aufzustellen
ja also meine dazu liegen ja bisher noch
gar keine daten vor ob das jetzt
irgendwie gut ist oder schlecht aber man
würde einfach sagen tja da spricht
eigentlich nichts dagegen wenn man
könnte einfach statt dann wenn das astra
zeneca so nicht sein soll dann eben
einen anderen geben denn das was an
antigenen ja dann präsentiert wird im
immunsystem das ist ziemlich ähnlich und
wird dann eben schon nochmal zu diesem
boostern beitragen das heißt also was
eben mit der ersten impfung anreiz
gesetzt ist dass das immunsystem sich
damit auseinandersetzt das sollte in der
zweiten impfung noch mal verstärkt
werden und das kann auch ein anderer
impfstoff leisten das ist eigentlich
ziemlich wahrscheinlich von gottberg wir
werden uns morgen der phoenix runde mit
dem thema lockdown besonders
beschäftigen wenn nicht die bis zum ende
dieser impfkampagne oder bis man diese
so genannte durchimpfung um hat kann es
ja sein dass uns dieser lockdown der ein
oder anderen form hat es gibt jetzt
massive widerstände innerhalb der
politik von der wirtschaft auch von den
menschen gerade übrigens auch in den
gebieten wo besonders viele menschen
erkrankt sind mit hohen incident ziehen
kann die politik das noch lange
durchhalten gibt wird der impfschutz der
jetzt zu sagen im anrollen ist der
politik noch die zeit geben diesen
locker und diese lockten politik die
außerordentlich unbeliebt ist noch
irgendwie unbeschadet zu überstehen also
wenn bund und länder das prinzip
hühnerhaufen weiter fortsetzen was sich
ja in den letzten mpk herausgestellt hat
dann wird das nicht gelingen
also dass man an dem einen beschluss
fasst und am nächsten tag dann in seinem
land
das gegenteil tut oder es in teilen
aufhebt oder sich sowieso sich sowieso
eine ganz andere regelung gibt als das
war wozu man am tag vorher noch ja
gesagt hat das halte ich für ganz
schwierig und da verliert man die leute
natürlich auch und wenn man jetzt schaut
dass es inzwischen nicht nur bund gegen
länder oder länder gehen ihren eigenen
weg dieses prinzip gibt sondern dass
inzwischen auch einzelne kommunen oder
schulen vor ort aufstehen gegen die
landesregierung und sagen ihr zwingt uns
dazu die schulen auf zu machen wir
wollen sie aber eigentlich schließen
weil die instanzen sind hier viel zu
hoch oder auch dass einzelne städte
städte sich selbstständig machen und
ihre ganz eigenen regelungen treffen
es ist in ordnung dass man vor ort
regionale die dinge also den lockdown
regional anpasst an das
infektionsgeschehen das finde ich völlig
in ordnung aber es muss ja so einen
rahmen geben und man hat immer wieder
versucht diesen rahmen zu setzen
aber immer wieder wird daraus
ausgebrochen bestes beispiel brandenburg
man hatte ja als obergrenze die inzidenz
von 100 also 100 infektionen binnen
sieben tagen bei 100000 einwohnern in
das papier geschrieben und brandenburg
sagt auf einmal für uns gilt die
notbremse erst ab 200 incident und das
ist dann tatsächlich ein problem weil
diese chaostage sind erst zu ende wenn
tatsächlich jedem ein impf angebot
gemacht worden ist und es möglichst
viele auch angenommen haben die
bundeskanzlerin hat sich ja vor einiger
zeit mal festgelegt mit dem herbstanfang
ist das noch realistisch mit der bitte
um eine kurze andere ich hoffe das
wissen
ich hoffe dass wir dann kommen wir
müssen halt einfach impfstoff bekommen
dann wird es auch dann wird das auch
passieren also insofern kann man das nur
hoffen wir könnten nicht erzwingen will
sitzen nicht in der an der glaskugel
aber das wäre jetzt etwas was helfen
könnte
gut dann werden wir die sendung die
phoenix runde mit
gerade weil die glaskugel ja immer noch
überall herum steht und wir noch nicht
so genau durchblicken dann auch uns
versuchen der wahrheit und den fakten
weiter zunehmen so schwierig das auch
ist ich bedanke mich bei eva quadbeck
bei timo ulrichs bei susanne schreiber
und bei ulrich weigelt für die sendung
live zuschauer
ich habe es gerade schon angedeutet
morgen in der phoenix runde das thema zu
wenig
doch zuviel lockdown krisen management
selbst in der krise